[ __ ] that what was that
so those sounds are the sounds of the
little jibber jabbers behind me I don't
know what that is do I have a dog and
[Music]
and why is dog know come protect me okay
so the first night is never usually that
bad in any of the game so I'll play
through why am I in this hellhole why is
any of this a hellhole in the first
place why does a child's life have to be
a hellhole I thought I saw a beak
thrusting at me from the darkness oh I
see
god damn it holy [ __ ] oh boy oh man whoo
I don't want to say anything in case I
missed something and I know I'd do
anything in case I do something god damn
it take your cupcake I'm Raymond okay
fudgesicles get out of here fudgesicles
fudge crap tickles what was that what
was that what was that this is a dog
again
okey-dokey dokey you better get out of
here doggie there be monsters around
here doggie
you better move on little dogie that's
Debbie steps [ __ ] you just stay stay
stay stay
good boy going boy down doggie okay okay
boys ooh cute he's so cute I wish you'd
go to hell enjoy so cute hey buddy
OOP gotcha
yes I might be able to beat right I
might be able to roll right into the
fifth night if I can do this right if I
can do it right it'll be good okay
[Applause]
so this is gonna suck but as you all
know I am the tank a five nights at
freddys and I will not give up my crown
to anybody who wants to impersonate a
golden freddy or a nightmare fredbear or
whatever his name is now I'm gonna beat
him and I'm gonna do it very quietly
because I'm gonna listen very closely
for it who wants my crown king of five
nights at freddys crown $0.99 marked
down from five old king sucks dong can't
play game right game on
he's a stem stomping he just stomping
Whomper he just jumpy wumpy Wampus woo
maybe I am supposed to listen because
Alice that was messed up he was like bam
and bam and bam and bam she's going to
be a it's going to be an ass blasting
[ __ ] Lloyd oh [ __ ] [ __ ] balls and [ __ ]
[Music]
with skill and triumph I'm dreaming dear
I'll buy that crown back for like a
dollar on three one two my whole world
is turned upside down good good good
good good good good good you get a get a
get together
lucky flannel been a vital up in this
business open the business mommy's here
to throw you into the closet never
remember you already want this whoo come
along you 1 P 1 per French you want a
whump aah whump it's whoo
bunch of poopy dicks [ __ ] balls oh snap
authenticity snap it's da damn 20 20 20
20 months and you thinking about boobies
you just want to keep flashing non-stop
you thinking about boobs in there you
thinking about boobs to bunch up boobie
boobs so ready for this I have
officially reclaimed my crown
five days
[Applause]
[Music]